hello reject nation ville home
I'm Greg this is who's dressed like the
Joker today that's a wig ain't real
this is a hundred percent unbelievable
she's not sexy redhead anymore she's
sexy green ever plaster on the amber
plaster shadow catcher on afterbuzz TV
and a whole bunch of other things online
just follow her we've seen the Baywatch
trailers we saw one right we thought one
well guess what this is only enjoyed and
we enjoyed it this is a red bass
you never forget the one who steals your
heart yeah or the one so [ __ ] [ __ ] is
happening our Beach and my balls say we
need to go over there check it out good
bad I do this weird life go my ball day
is ready for my balls are things [ __ ]
that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies they watch work because we
follow rules
this got a train wreck that Brody and
not a single oxygen that pours in the
whole world like it's a human again
which is impossible to be so cool you
got don't jack off on my sheep just
remember I'm always watching
[Music]
good luck we need to search for more
credits
check this painfully tomorrow I'm going
to check his change from if this [ __ ]
scrotum and check it ain't it ain't news
if it ain't even look good closer
oh holy okay oh there's a homeless do
not post actors ahead full of balls left
now into the goddamn X game yes because
we were in the lifeguard pursuit oh okay
okay
except there's no [ __ ] such thing as
life gone yes I feel like this is just
made for Dwayne Johnson yeah a little
bit the rock Shelly I don't really like
he's the reason I want to watch this
movie
absolutely I want to watch it for Zac
Efron - I like my Zac Effron ongoing
he's kind of like he's feeling a little
off yeah a little bit like a little bit
like a little bit like owning how
weirdly douchey he is Zac Efron is kind
of going down as real self-deprecating
route I think it's a great choice it's a
great choice because he was really
introduced onto the scene as this pretty
boy because never says stuff like
neighbors where he's really willing to
make fun of himself it's really helped
with his image yeah I'm like oh it's
okay to make fun of this guy because
he's okay with it - because he has a
sense of humor but I can't stand pretty
boys who take themselves too seriously I
can't stand free people who take
themselves too sir I don't like pretty
people in general pretty people can die
there are really the ugliest people if
you think about it like ever and I are
the ugliest people because of how pretty
we actually are in here in here ugly
this pretty
right I haven't seen the I feel like I
might be missing a movie where he had
this much swear words of vulgarity in a
long time because I feel like usually
does these pg-13 action comedies in
comedy if you have a big dude won't be
angry generally speaking it takes the
comedy a little bit out of it a little
bit yeah because you know that like a
big jack dude could actually hurt you
the comedy leaves Ruhlman sounds like a
little fear so their language or
whatever it kinds makes economy out of
it so I think he has to do almost like
over the top to make it push it back in
the comments so that you know it's
ridiculous yeah I think so this trailer
showed how much more wacky this movie
actually is going to be like I hope they
would image the fish think about that
everybody a little bit of like the
cadence of the movie Step Brothers yeah
yeah that is sort like you think you
didn't like just ridiculous it's based
on this bro banter but that's so there
are times were just so heightened Lee
ridiculous then like that's not really
enough this selfie selfie oh and the
ball Gavin is there's so much vulgarity
in here I like the rock in comedies I
think he's a hilarious actor I just
don't recall the last time using
something that would sit heavily R rated
in terms of dialogue and I'm like I
played these action heroes who don't
really get fazed by violence like with
the foot good luck good luck like you're
ready yeah Reza's character and central
intelligence where he's just like
everything is normal to him actually
like that movie I know a lot of people
didn't like that I thought it was really
funny and I thought the rock was the
best part of that but yeah I agree
seeing this it's like an r-rated version
of that type of character at what it is
yeah see I hit the nail on the head yeah
and who's that one actress the what a
blows off Zac Efron yeah oh yeah sorry
oh uh I'm hot girl that's her name she's
in the San Andreas she's also not I
don't hmm
we know that when I guess that I don't
like I don't know her for being funny I
don't think she's meant to be funny okay
I think she's meant to be eye candy with
possible talent I think that's more what
she's known for I feels like all the
comedy really relies on all the guys in
this room yeah
which is unfortunate it's unfortunate
but it kind of works with a Baywatch day
or yeah like as a feminist I like yeah I
do actually because the whole point
because Baywatch was already mocked for
me to show that like specialized women
yeah and I'm like oh that's what the
movies going to do it's probably back to
have fun making fun of that too yeah and
she was in San Andreas as Dwayne
Johnson's daughter oh I really hope they
don't hook up I hope they do
cuz that would be the craziest thing
they could do for this movie I want to
see that interviewer they're like so
what was it like playing her father and
then and then the does her leather her
in the next movie that would be awesome
Dwayne that's every father's dream for
you natural yeah I feel like Dwayne you
also could do it Mina cordial anything
she's gorgeous
yes obviously I kiss her and that's it
waiting till marriage that is all I'm
gonna do I am excited so I'll be
watching it this looks like a
hilariously good time yeah I'd be very
surprised if I did it last twice can
attend would recommend this trailer
again might even watched again wow
that's solid yeah had high expectations
edition very high I'm expecting
character development I'm expecting at
the rock and Zac Efron will get along in
the air I need to laugh so hard that I
like cough or cry
I wonder if Dwayne Johnson really gave
Zac Efron a lot of crap on set because I
know that Dwayne Johnson and Kevin Hart
have that I Holly hammer up again that
he'd likes to clown on him and I feel
like he probably does that's a Zac Efron
as well I feel like the Zac Efron can't
do multiple funny movies without
actually being a guy who is
self-deprecating and like I was people
to make fun of him she used to work it
out of LA Fitness I go to that guy
founder of the rock second the Rockies
are the tire Jim to himself
the rock works at Messina Valley
apparently does a see what buildings
entire like subscribe to do the real
rejects hey we recently watch the
patreon
how many wonderful beautiful people have
been going over there becoming a part of
the patron community hell yeah have
exclusive video content on their movie
news we have interviews we got all kinds
of goodies over there I'm telling you
the support has been amazing it's been
filling up my testicles so much that's
what I call that work how do you feel
about your patrons I love my patrons and
how do you feel about your pictures yeah
I really appreciate you guys as leader
help is really helping support the whole
channel so thank you guys a member
platte sir you could follow amber
plaster on the amber plaster channel
she's also an afterbuzz TV and she has a
lot of social media no bikini pics
because she's got a horror-movie cousin
tail